As part of Mit course success,
zero,
nine,
nine on artificial general intelligence,
I got a chance to sit down and Christof
Koch,
who's one of the seminal figures in
neurobiology and neuroscience and
generally in the study of consciousness.
He's the president,
the chief scientific officer of the
Allen Institute for Brain Science in
Seattle from 1986 to 2013.
He was the professor at Caltech before
that he was at mit.
He is extremely well cited,
over 100,000
citations.
His research,
his writing,
his ideas have had big impact on the
scientific community and the general
public in the way we think about
consciousness in the way we see
ourselves as human beings.
He's the author of several books,
the quest of consciousness in Europe,
biological approach,
and a more recent book consciousness,
confessions of a romantic reductionist.
If you enjoy this conversation,
this course,
subscribe,
click the little bell icon to make sure
you never miss a video and in the
comments,
leave suggestions for any people you'd
like to see.
Be Part of the course or any ideas that
you would like us to explore.
Thanks very much and I hope you enjoy.
Okay.
Before we delve into the beautiful
mysteries of consciousness,
let's zoom out a little bit and let me
ask,
do you think there's intelligent life
out there in the universe or.
Yes,
I do believe so.
We have no evidence of it,
but I think the possibilities are
overwhelming in favor of it.
Give them a universe of where we have 10
to 11 galaxies and each galaxy has
between 10 to 11,
10 to the twelfth
stars.
And we know most stars have one or more
planet.
So how does that make you feel?
It still makes me feel special because I
have experiences.
I feel the world experienced the world
and uh,
independent of whether they are other
creatures out there.
I still feel the world and I have access
to this world in this very strange,
compelling way.
And that's the core of human existence.
Now you said human.
Do you think if those intelligent
creatures are out there,
do you think they experience their
world?
That's true.
They
evolved.
If they are a product of natural
evolution,
if they would have to be,
they will also experience the owned
world.
The consciousness isn't just Schumann.
You hide it.
It's much wider.
It's probably.
It may be spread across all of biology.
We have the only thing that we have
specialists.
We can talk about it.
I've got not all people can talk about
the babies and little children can talk
about a patient who have.
We have a stoke in the left.
Inferior frontal gyrus can talk about
it,
but most normal adult people can talk
about it and so we think that makes us
special compared to letting monkeys or
dogs or cats and mice,
all the other creatures that we share
the planet with,
but all the evidence seems to suggest
that they to experience the world and so
it's like overwhelmingly likely that
other alien that aliens would also
experience their world of course
differently because they have a
difference in psyllium.
They have different sense of.
They have a very different environment,
but the fact that I would strongly
support that they also have experiences
if your pain and pleasure and see in
some sort of spectrum and he,
uh,
and have all the other senses,
of course their language if they have
one,
will be different.
So women understand their poetry about
the experiences that they have.
That's correct.
Right.
So in a talk,
in a video,
I've heard you mentioned adac sound that
you came up with the you grew up with as
part of your family when you were young.
Uh,
first of all your technically a
midwestern boy.
He just technically after that,
a trial of that are on a bit and a
little bit of the accent.
You talked about supports all the taxol
and having these elements of human
humanness,
of consciousness that you discovered.
So I just wanted to ask,
can you look back in your childhood and
remember when was the first time you
realized you yourself sort of form a
third person perspective or our
conscious being this idea of no stepping
outside of yourself and seeing there's
something special going on here in my
brain.
I can't really accurate.
It's a good question.
I'm not sure I recall a discreet moment.
I mean you take it for granted because
that's the only world you know.
The only world I know you know is the
world of seeing and hearing voices and
touching and all the other thing,
so it's only much later at early in my
undergrad days when I became,
when I enrolled in physics and in
philosophy that I really thought about
it and thought,
well,
this is really fundamentally very,
very mysterious and there's nothing
really in physics right now that
explains this transition from the
physics of the brain to feelings.
Where do the feelings come in until you
can look at the foundational equation of
quantum mechanics,
general relativity.
You can look at the period table of the
elements.
You can look at the endless atg seat
chat and our genes and no is
consciousness.
Yet I wake up every morning to a world
where I have experiences and so that's
the hub of the ancient mind body
problem.
How do explain to get into the world?
So what is consciousness,
experience consciousness as any,
any con,
any experience?
Some people call it subjective feelings,
some people call it a phenomenon,
phenomenology,
some people call it quality of their
philosophy,
but they all did note the same thing.
It feels like something in the famous
word for the philosopher Thomas Nagel.
It feels like something to be a bad or
to be a,
uh,
an American or to be angry or to be sad
or to be in love or to have pain
and that is what experience is.
Any possible experience could be as
mundane as just sitting in a chair could
be as excited as,
you know,
having a mystical moment,
uh,
you know,
in,
in deep meditation,
those also just different forms of
experiences,
experience.
So if you were to sit down with maybe
the next,
skip a couple of generations of Ibm
Watson,
something that won jeopardy,
what is the gap?
I guess the question is between Watson,
uh,
that might be a much smarter than you
than us,
than all any human alive but may not
have experience.
What is the gap?
Well,
so that's a big,
big question that's occupy people for
the last,
certainly the last 50 years since we,
since the advent,
the birth of have a computer question
and chilling title answer and of course
he did it in this indirect way by
proposing it's tests and operational
tests.
So,
but that's not really,
that's,
you know,
he tried to get it.
What does it mean for a person to think
and then he had this test that you lock
them away and then you have a
communication with them and then you
title to guess after a whether that is a
personal or whether it's a computer
system.
There's no question that now or very
soon,
you know,
Alexa or Siri or Google,
now we'll pass this test and you can
game it.
But you know,
ultimately,
certainly in your generation there will
be machines that will speak with
complete poise that will remember
everything you've ever said that.
Remember every email you ever had like
Samantha,
remember in the movie her.
It's no question it's going to have a
happen,
but of course the key question is it
doesn't feel like anything to be
Samantha in the movie her or does it
feel like anything to be Watson and
there one has to be very,
very strongly think they're two
different concepts here that we call
mingle.
There is a concept of intelligence,
natural or artificial,
and there is a concept of consciousness
of experience,
natural or artificial.
Those are very,
very different things.
Now historically with associate
consciousness was intelligence.
Why?
Because we live in a world leaving aside
computers of of natural selection where
we're surrounded by creatures,
either our own kin that are less or more
intelligent or we go costs feces.
Some.
Some are more adapted to particular
environment.
Others unless adapted,
whether it's a whale or a dog or you go
talk to him or a little worm,
and we see the complexity of the nervous
system goes from one cell to two,
a specialized cells to a worm that has
been at that has 30 percent of its cells
and nerve cells to creature like us or
like a blue whale that have had 100
billion nerve cells and so based on
behavioral evidence and based on the
underlying neuroscience,
we believe that as his creatures become
more complex,
they are better adapted to their
particular ecological niche and they
become more conscious partly because
their brain calls and we believe
consciousness,
unlike the ancient ancient people
thought most almost every culture
thought that consciousness was
intelligence has to do with your heart
and you still see that today.
You see,
honey,
I love you with all my house,
but what you should actually say,
you say,
no honey,
I love you was all my lateral
hypothalamus and for Valentine's Day you
should give you a sweetheart,
a,
you know,
a hypothalamic shame piece of chocolate
and not a hardship chocolate.
Right?
So we still have this language,
but now we believe it's a brain and so
we see brains of different complexity
and we think,
well,
they have different levels of
consciousness that capable of different
experiences.
Um,
but now we confront a world where we
know where we're beginning to engineer
intelligence and it's graphical,
unclear whether the intelligence we
engineering has anything to do with
consciousness and whether it can
experience anything because
fundamentally what's the difference?
Intelligence.
It's about function intelligence,
no matter exactly how you define it,
sort of adaptation to new environments.
Being able to learn and quickly
understand the setup of this and what's
going on and who the actors and what's
going to happen next.
It's all about function.
Consciousness is not about function
consciousness,
it's about being in some sense,
much fundamental.
You can see folks that,
you can see this in several cases.
You can see it.
For instance,
in the case of the clinic,
when you're dealing with patients who
are,
let's say had a stoke or had one traffic
accident,
etc.
They're pretty much immobile.
Terry shy boy,
you may have heard historically,
she was a person here in the in the
nineties and Florida judge heart stood
still.
She was really animated and for the next
14 years she was in a vegetative state,
so there's thousands of people in a
vegetative state,
so they're,
you know,
they are,
they're like this.
Occasionally they opened the eyes for
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
eight hours and then close the eyes.
They have sleep,
wake cycle.
Occasionally they have behavior they do,
but there's no way that you can
establish a lawful relationship between
what you say or the doctor says or the
mom says and what the patient does.
So,
so the.
So the.
There isn't any behavior.
Get in some of these people.
There is still experience.
You can,
you can design and build brain machine
interfaces where you can see there's
still experienced something and of
course that these cases have blocked in
state.
There's a famous book called the diving
bell and the butterfly.
Well,
you had an ediTor to edit a year.
The stoke in the in the brain stem,
unable to move except his vertical eyes,
eye movement.
he could just move his eyes up and down.
When you dictated an entire book and
some people even lose this at the end it
all the evidence seems to suggest that
they're still in there.
In this case,
you have no behavior.
You have consciousness.
Second cases tonight,
like all of us,
you're going to go to sleep,
close your eyes,
you go to sleep.
You will wake up inside your sleeping
body and you will have conscious
experiences are different from everyday
experience.
You might fly.
You might not be surprised that you're
flying.
You might meet a long dead pet childhood
dog and you're not surprised that you're
meeting them,
you know,
but you have conscious experience of
love,
of hates.
You know they can be very emotional.
Your body during this state,
it typically to them state sends an
active signal to your motor neurons to
paralyze you.
it's called tanya because if you don't
have that,
like some patients,
what do you do?
You act out your dreams.
You get proximal behavioral disorder,
which is about,
which is bad juju to get.
Okay.
Sad case is pure experience.
so I recently had this,
what some people call it mystical
experience.
I went to Singapore and went into
flotation tank,
right?
So this is a big tub filled was with
water.
That's body temperature and epsom salt.
You strip completely naked,
july,
inside of it,
you close the lid,
darkness,
complete darkness,
soundproof.
So very quickly you become body less
because you're floating and you're
naked.
You have no rings,
no watch,
no nothing.
You don't feel your body anymore.
No sound soundless.
There's no a photon,
a sightless timeless because after a
while,
early on,
you're actually hear your heart,
but then that you sort of adapt to that
and then sort oF the pathogen of time,
csus,
and if you train yourself like in a,
in a meditation,
not to sleep early on,
you think a lot,
it's a little bit spooky,
you feel somewhat uncomfortable or you
think,
well,
I'm going to get bored,
but if your title not to think actively,
you become mindless.
So there you are.
Body less timeless.
Soundless sightless mindless.
But you're in a conscious experience,
you're not asleep,
you're,
you,
you are being a pure,
pure being.
There isn't any function.
You aren't doing any computation,
you're not remembering,
you're not projecting,
you're not planning yet.
You are fully conscious,
fully conscious.
There is something going out there.
It could be just a side effect.
So what is the,
the epi phenomenon.
So what is the select effect?
Meaning why?
Uh,
what,
what is the function of you being able
to lay in this sense,
sensory free deprivation tank and still
have a conscious experience?
Obviously we didn't evolve with
flotation tanks in our environment.
I mean,
so biology is notoriously bad at asking
why.
Question anomic question,
why do we have two eyes?
Why don't we have four or three hours or
something?
Well,
no,
there's probably a bit.
It'S a function to that,
but it's,
we're not very good at answering those
questions.
We can speculate.
And leslie were biologists or
scientists,
very good about mechanistic question,
why they're charging the universe,
right?
We find the universe were there positive
and negative charges.
Why?
Why does quantum mechanics hall?
you know,
why,
why doesn't some other theory,
quantum mechanics in our university?
It's very unclear why so tiller,
comical question,
why questions are difficult to answer.
Clearly there's some relationship
between complexity,
brain processing,
power and consciousness,
but however,
in these cases,
in these three that I gave,
one is an everyday experience at night.
The other one is a tom on third one is
in principle.
You can.
Everybody can have these sort of
mystical experiences.
You have a dissociation of function form
of intelligence from
I'm from conscious and unconscious.
This you caught me asking a why
question.
Let me ask a question that's not a why
You're giving a talk later today on the
turing test for intelligence and causes
a drawn lines between the two.
So is there a scientific way to say
there's consciousness present in this
entity or not?
And to anticipate your answer because
you will also.
There's a neuro biological answer.
So we test the human brain,
but if you take a machine brain that you
don't know tests for yet a,
how would you even begin to approach a
test of their consciousness precedent in
this thing?
Okay,
that's a really good question.
So let me take two steps.
So as you point out for for four months,
let's just stick with humans.
There's now a test called a zap unzip.
It's a procedure where you ping the
brain using transcranial magnetic
stimulation,
you look at the electrical
reverberations essentially using egg and
then you can measure the complexity of
this brain response and you can do this
in a weight.
People in asleep sleep,
normal people.
You can do it in a wake people up and
then anesthetize them.
you can do it in patients and it it,
it has a hundred percent accuracy that
in all those cases when you're clear the
patient or the person that either
conscious or unconscious a complexity
either high or low and then you can
adopt these techniques to similar
creatures like monkeys and dogs and,
and,
and mindset have very similar planes.
Now of course you,
you point out that may not help you
because we don't have a context,
you know,
and if I send them magnetic pulse into
my iphone or my computer,
it's probably going to break something.
Yeah.
So we don't have that.
so what we need,
ultimately,
we need a theory of consciousness.
We can just align our intuition,
our intuition as well.
Yeah.
If somebody talks,
they're conscious,
right?
However,
then they all these children,
babies don't talk.
Right?
But we believe that that,
that baby's also have conscious
experiences.
Right?
And then there are all these patients I
mentioned and they don't talk.
When you dream,
you can't talk because you're paralyzed.
So.
So what?
What we ultimately need,
we can't just rely on our intuition.
We need a theory of content that tells
us what is it about a piece of matter?
What is it about a piece of highly
excitable map?
I like the brain or like a computer that
gives rise to conscious experience.
We all believe,
none of us believe that anymore in the
old story.
It's a soul that used to be the most
common explanation that most people
accept it.
And still a lot of people today believe,
well there's god endowed.
Only asked was his special thing that
animals don't have.
They need to call.
Famously said,
dog,
if you hit it with your,
catch me yell at me,
but it doesn't have this special thing.
It doesn't have the magic,
the magic sauce.
It doesn't have guys downstairs.
So now we believe that isn't the case
anymore.
So what is the difference between brains
and,
and these guys?
Silicon and um,
in particular once their behavior
matches.
So if you have siri,
you have alexa in 20 years from now that
she can talk just as good as any
possible schumann,
what counts do you have to say?
She's not conscious in particular.
If she says,
as I've caught,
you will cause I'm conscious you also,
what are you doing?
and she'll say,
well,
you know,
they,
they'll generate some way to cost she,
she'll behave like a,
like a person.
Now there's several differences.
One is,
so this relates to the problem,
the very hot.
Why is consciousness a hard problem?
It's because it's subjective,
right?
Only I have it for one.
I know I have direct experience of my
own consciousness.
I don't have eczema.
And your consciousness now,
I assume as a sort of a bayesian
personal believes in probability theory
in all of that,
you know,
I can do,
I can do an abduction to the,
to the best available tax I did use.
Your brain is very similar to mine.
If I put you in a scanner,
your brain is going to behave the same
with I do.
If,
if,
if you know,
if I gave you this muesli and ask you
how does it taste?
You tell me things that you know,
that,
that I would also say more or less
higher.
So infer based on all of them that your
conscious now it was silly.
I can't do that.
So there I really need a theory that
tells me what is it about,
about any system,
this or this.
It makes it conscious.
We have such a theory.
Yes.
So the integrated information theory,
but let me first maybe as an
introduction for people who are not
familiar,
the car.
Can yOu talk a lot about panpsychism?
can you describe what a physicalism
versus dualism?
The.
You mentioned the soul.
What is the history of that idea?
What is the idea of penn psychosis or.
No,
the debate really out of which
panpsychism can emerge of,
of,
um,
dualism versus a physicalism or do you
not see a panpsychism as fitting into
that?
No,
you can argue there's some older.
Okay.
So let's step back.
So panpsychism is a very ancient belief
that's been around a plato and aristotle
talks about it.
A modern philosophers talk about it.
Of course in buddhism the idea is very
prevalent that,
I mean the different versions of it.
one version says everything is
installed.
Everything,
rocks and stones and dogs and people and
foremost an iphone.
All of her soul.
I'd all,
matt is in seoul.
That's sort of one version.
Another version is that all biology,
all creatures smaller,
large from a single cell to a giant
quietly feel like something that's the
one I think is somewhat more realistic.
Um,
so they're different.
What do you mean by feel like something?
I have a feeling,
have some kind of like,
some,
it may well be possible that it feels
like something to be a power medium.
I think it's pretty likely it feels like
something to be a b or a mouse or dog.
Sure.
So,
okay,
so,
so that you can see that's also.
So pam is very broad and you can some
people,
for example,
a proton mccastle try to advocate this.
This idea is called alien monism that,
that panpsychism is really physics
viewed from the inside.
So the idea is that physics is very good
at describing relationship among objects
like charges or like gravity,
you know,
this relationship between curvature and
mass distribution.
Okay.
That's the relationship among things.
Physics doesn't really discard the
ultimate reality itself.
It's just relationship among quarks or
all these other stuff was sort of like a
third observer.
Yes.
And consciousness is what physics feels
on the inside to my conscious
experience.
It's a way that physics of my brain,
particular my cortex feels from the
inside.
And so if you meet them,
you to remember you say panamanian,
well that's a pretty dumb creature this,
but it has already a billion different
molecules probably,
you know,
5,000
different proteins assemble in a highly,
highly complex system that no single
person,
no computer system so far on this planet
has ever managed to accurately simulate
its complexity.
Vastly escapes us.
Yes.
And it may well be that that little
thing feels like a tiny bit.
No,
it doesn't have a voice in their head
like me.
It doesn't have expectations,
you know,
it doesn't have all that complex things,
but it may well feel like something.
Yeah.
So This is really interesting.
Can we draw some lines and maybe try to
understand the difference between life
intelligence and consciousness.
How do you see all of those?
If she has to define what is a living
thing,
what is a conscious thing and what is an
intelligent thing?
Do those intermix for you?
Or are they totally separate or.
Okay.
So a,
that's a question that we don't have a
full.
And a lot of this stuff we're talking
about today is full of mysteries.
And fascinating ones,
right it,
while the approximately you can go to
other startle who's probably the most
important scientists and philosophers
ever lived in.
Certainly in western culture.
He had this idea,
it's called hylomorphism.
It's quite popular these days that there
are different forms of soul.
The soul is really the form of something
he saw.
He says,
all biological kj have a vegetive soul.
That's life principle today we think we
understand something molded it's
biochemistry and nonlinear
thermodynamics,
right?
Then he said they have a sensitive,
so only animals and humans have also a
sensitive soul or an appetitive soul.
They can see,
they can smell and they have drives.
They wanted tO put,
reproduce,
they want to eat,
et cetera,
and then only humans have what he called
a rational soul.
Okay.
And that idea that made it into
christian dome and then the rational
soul is the one that lives forever.
He was very unclear.
he wasn't really,
I mean different readings or virustotal
give different what that did he believe
that international show was a model or
not,
but I probably think he didn't,
but then of course had made it into a
play to under christianity and then this
all became immortal and then became the
the connection to god.
Now you,
so you were asking me essentially,
what does our modern conception of these
fleet aristotle would have called them
different forms live.
We think we know something about it,
at least live on this planet,
although we don't understand how to
originated,
but it's been difficult to rigorously
pin down.
You see this in modern definition of
death.
It's the fact that I had.
Now there's a conference ongoing.
Again,
that ties to defined legally and
medically.
What is death?
It used to be very simple.
As you stop breathing,
your heart stops beating your dad.
Totally unconverted lead.
If you're unsure you wait another 10
minutes.
If the patient doesn't please,
you know he's dead.
Well,
now we have ventilators.
We have half of a peacemaker,
so it's much more difficult to define.
What this is typically does is defined
at the end of life and life has defined
before death before that.
Okay.
So we don't have really very good
definitions.
Intelligence,
we don't have a rigorous definition.
We know something how to measure it,
called iq or gi factors hide and,
and we're beginning to build it in,
in a narrow sense.
I'd like go alphago and,
and,
and watson and you know,
google cars and uber cars and all of
that.
That's still now I am.
some people are thinking about
artificial general intelligence,
but actually as we've said before,
it's something to do with ability to
learn and to adapt to new environments.
But that is,
as I said,
also,
it's radical difference from experience
and it's very unclear if you build a
machine that has agi,
it's not at all,
not at all clear that this machine will
have consciousness.
It may or may not.
So let's ask it the other way.
Do you think if you were to try to build
an artificial general intelligence
system,
can you think,
uh,
figuring out how to build artificial
consciousness?
What would help you get to an agi?
So or put another way,
do you think intelligent requires
consciousness in shumen it goes hand in
hand
in shumen or.
I think in biology,
consciousness and intelligence goes hand
in hand.
Quite is illusion because the plane
evolved to be highly complex.
Complexity via this theory,
integrated information theory is sort of
ultimately is what is closely tied to
consciousness.
Ultimately it's causal power upon itself
and so in evolution evolved systems ego
together in artificial system,
particularly in digital machines,
they do not go together and if you ask
me,
point blank is alexa 20 point,
oh,
in the year 20,
41,
she can easily pass every two
intestines.
She conscious no.
Even if she claims she's concert.
In fact,
you could even do more radical version
of this thought experiment.
We can build a computer simulation of
the human brain.
you know what henry markram in the blue
brain project or the human brain project
in Switzerland,
it's kind of do them all the success.
So in 10 years we have this perfect
simulation of the human brain.
Every new owner stimulated and it has
alarm makes and it has motor neuron.
It has a pocket area and of course talk
and they'll say,
hi,
I just woke up.
I feel great.
Okay.
Even that computer simulation that can
imprint so map onto your brain will not
be conscious.
Why?
Because it simulates.
It's a difference between this simulated
in the real,
so it simulates the behavior salted with
consciousness.
It might be,
it will.
If it's done properly,
we'll have all the intelligence that
that particular person they're
simulating has,
but simulating intelligence,
it's not the same as having conscious
experiences and I give you a really nice
metaphor that engineers and physicists
typically get.
I can write down einStein's field
equations nine or 10 equations that
describe the lincoln general relativity
between curvature and and mass.
I can do that.
I can run this on my laptop to to
predict that the sample,
the black hole at the center of our
galaxy will be so massive that it twists
space time around it so no light can
escape it.
It'S a black hole,
but funny.
have you ever wondered,
why doesn't this computer simulation
suck me in ict?
It simulates gravity,
but it doesn't have the causal power of
gravity.
IT's a huge difference.
So it's a difference between the real
and the simulator,
just like it doesn't get wet inside the
computer when the computer code that
similar to weather a storm and so in
order to have to have artificial
continents,
you have to give it the same.
Causal powers is human brain.
You have to build,
took all the new amorphic machine that
has hardware that is very similar to the
human brain,
not a digital
clark for nine computer.
So that's just to clarify thouGh,
you think that consciousness is not
required to create human level
intelligence.
It seems to accompany in the human
brain,
but for machine not have court.
So maybe just because this is agi.
Let's dig in a little bit about what we
mean by intelligence.
So one thing is the g factor,
these kinds of iq tests of intelligence,
but I think if you maybe another way to
say,
so in 20,
40,
20,
50 people have siri that is just really
impressive.
Do you Think people will say series
intelligent?
Yes.
Intelligence.
Is this a morphous thing?
So to be intelligent,
it seems like you have to have some kind
of connections with other human beings
in a sense that you have to impress them
with your intelligence and their fields.
You have to somehow operate in this
world full of humans and for that there
feels like there has to be something
like consciousness.
So you think you can have just the
world's best natural lp system,
natural language,
understanding regeneration,
and that will be,
that will get us happy and say,
you know what,
we've created an agi happy.
Yes,
I do believe we can get what we call
high level functional intelligence,
sort of
the,
gee,
you know,
this,
this fluid like intelligence that we
challenged,
particularly the place like mit,
right in,
in,
in machines.
I see apple,
you know,
reasons and I've see a lot of reason to
believe it's going to happen,
you know,
over the next 50 years or 30 years.
So for beneficial ai for creating an ai
system.
That's um,
so you mentioned ethics that is
exceptionally intelligent but also does
not do,
does aligns its values with our values
as humanity.
Do you think then in his consciousness,
yes.
I think that that is a verY good
argument that if we're concerned about
ai and the threat of ai are nick bostrom
existentialist,
dread.
I think having an intelligent that has
empathy,
right?
Why do we find abusing a dog?
Why do most of us find that upholland
abusing any animal?
I'd.
Why do we find that the holland,
because we have this thing called
empathy,
which if you look at the greek really
means feeling with I feel empathy.
I have feeling with you.
I see somebody else suffer.
That isn't even my conspecific I.
It's not a person.
It's not a lot,
but it's not my wife or my kids.
It's a dog,
but I feel naturally most of us,
not all of us,
most of us will feel emphatic and so it
may well be in the longterm interest of
survival of homo sapiens.
Sapiens said,
if we do build agi and it's really
becomes very powerful that it has an
emphatic response and doesn't just
exterminated humanity.
So as part of the full
conscious experience,
uh,
to,
to create a consciousness artificial or
in our human consciousness,
do you think fear,
maybe we're going to get it into your
earlier days in each and so on,
but do you think fear and suffering are
essential,
uh,
to have consciousness?
Do you have to have the full range of
experience to have,
to have a system that has experienced or
can you have a system that only has a
very particular kinds of very positive
experience?
Look you can have in Pennsylvania,
you can.
People have done this in the vat.
Will you implanted electrodes in the
hypothalamus,
the pleasure center of the bat and that
stimulated sob above and beyond anything
else?
It doesn't care about food or natural
sex or drink anymore to stimulate itself
because it's such a pleasurable feeling.
I guess it's like an orgasm just you'll
have,
you know,
all day long.
And so I see no reason why you need
different,
why you need a great variety now.
Clearly to survive that wouldn't work.
But if I engineered artificially,
I don't think,
I don't think you need a great variety
of conscious experience.
You could have just pleasure or just
feel it might be a tablet systems,
but I think that's possible,
at least on conceptual logical can cause
any real creature,
whether artificially engineered.
Do you want to give it fear,
the fear of extinction that we all have
a.
And you also want to give it a positive
competitive states states that it wants
to,
that you want the machine in coach to do
because if they give the machine
positive feedback.
So you mentioned panpsychism to jump
back a little bit,
you know,
everything having some kind of mental
property,
uh,
how,
how do you go from there to something
like human consciousness?
So everything having some elements of
consciousness to.
Well,
is there something special about human
consciousness?
What's so just,
it's not everything like a sport.
There's no.
The of panpsychism I think of,
well,
it doesn't ski consciousness to anything
like this,
the spoon or my liver.
However,
uh,
it is,
the theory of integrated information
theory.
It does say that system,
even ones that look from the outside,
the relatively simple,
at least if they have this internal
calvo power,
they are the.
It does feel like something.
The theory I polio doesn't say anything.
What's special about schumann
biologically we know what the one thing
that's special about human is we speak
and we have an overblown sense of our
own importance,
right?
Can we believe we are exceptional and
we're just god's gift to,
to into the universe,
but the but behaviorally the main thing
that we have,
we can plan,
we can plan or the longterm and we have
language and that gives us enormous
amount of power.
That's why we are the dominant species
on the planet.
So you mentioned god,
you grew up a devout roman catholic,
a roman catholic family.
So you know what consciousness you're
sort of exploring some really deeply
fundamental human things that religion
also touches on.
So where does,
where does religion fit into your
thinking about consciousness and you've,
you've grown throughout your life and
changed your views on religion as far as
I understand.
Yeah.
I mean I'm not much closer to.
So I'm not a roman catholic anymore,
I don't believe there's sort of this
god,
the god I was,
I was educated to believe in,
you know,
sit somewhere in the fullness of time.
I'll be united in some sort of
everlasting bliss.
I just don't see any evidence for that.
look,
the world the night is large and full of
wonders.
there are many things that I don't
understand.
I think many things that we as a cult,
he look,
we don't even understand more than four
percent of all the,
uh,
universe,
dark matter,
dark energy.
We have no idea what it is.
MayBe it's lost socks.
What do I know?
So,
so all I can tell you is sort of my,
my current religious or spiritual
sentiment is much closer to some form of
buddhism.
Can you just tell debbie income,
asian?
Unfortunately,
there's no evidence for reincarnation.
So can you describe a way buddhism sees
the world a little bit?
Well,
so the,
you know,
they talk about.
So when I spent several meetings with,
with the dalai lama and what always
impressed me about him,
he really,
unlike,
for example,
a t there,
the pope or some cottonelle,
he emphasize
minimizing the suffering of all
creatures.
So they have this from the early
beginning.
They look at suffering in all creatures,
not just in people,
but in everybody.
This universal and of course by degrees,
right?
An animal child Will have a less,
is less capable of suffering than a,
than a well developed a normally
developed human and um,
they think consciousness pervades in
this universe and they have these
techniques,
you know,
you can think of them like mindfulness,
etc.
in meditation that ties to access sort
of what they claim of this more
fundamental aspect of reality.
I'm not sure it's more fundamentalist.
I think about it.
There's a physical and then there's this
insight you consciousness.
and those are the two aspects.
That's the only thing I've,
I've access to in my life.
And you've got to remember my conscious
expense and you're consciously explains,
comes prior to anything you know about
physics comes pi to knowledge about the
universe and atoms and superstrings and
molecules and all of that.
The only thing you directly acquainted
with this world that's populated with
things in images and sounds in your head
and touch us and all of that.
I actually have a question.
So it sounds like you kind of have a
rich life.
You talk about rock climbing and it
seems like you really love literature
and conscious ness is all about
experiencing things.
So do you think that has helped your
research on this topic?
Yeah.
Yes.
Particularly if you think about it,
the value of statesville program when
you do are climbing or now I do.
I'm going in a bike everyday you can get
into this thing called the zone and I've
always wanted.
I wanted above about a particular with
respect to continence because it's a
strangely addictive state.
You want to,
you want to appear.
I mean,
once people have had ones who want to
keep on going back to it and you wonder
why,
what is it so addicting about it,
and I think it's the experience of,
of almost close to pure experience
because in this,
in this zone,
you're not conscious of inner voice
anymore.
There's always the inner voice nagging
you or do you have to do this?
You have to do that.
You have to pay your taxes.
He had this fight with your ex and all
of those things are always there,
but when you're in the zone,
all of that is gone and your justice in
this wonderful state,
while you're fully out in the world,
you're,
you're climbing or biking or doing
soccer,
what or whatever you're doing and sort
of consciousness sort of.
It says you're all action,
or in this case,
a pure experience.
You're not actually at all,
but in both cases you experienced some
aspect of of con.
You touched some basic part of of,
of conscious existence and it's so basic
and so deeply satisfying you.
I think you tapped the award of being.
That's really what you're touching
there.
You're getting close to the root of
being and that's very different from
intelligence.
So what do you think about
the simulation hypothesis,
simulation theory,
the idea that we all live in a computer
simulation.
Have you done that?
Just put notes,
laptops for nerds,
for nerds.
I think it's as likely as the hypothesis
that engaged
hundreds of scholars for many centuries.
Are we all just existing in the mind of
god?
Right?
And this is just a modern version of it.
It's,
it's,
it's equally plausible.
People love talking about these types of
things.
I know that book written.
So what the simulation hypothesis.
If that's what people want to do,
that's fine.
Seems ratHer esoteric.
It's never testable,
but it's not useful for you to think of
it in those terms.
So maybe connecting to the questions of
freewill,
which you've talked about.
Um,
I,
I think vaguely remember you saying that
the idea that there is no freewill,
uh,
it makes you very uncomfortable.
Uh,
so what do you think about freewill in,
from,
from a physics perspective,
from a conscious perspective,
what does it all fit?
Okay.
So from the physics perspective,
leaving aside quantum mechanics,
we believe we live in a fully
deterministic world,
right?
But then comes up course quantum
mechanics.
So now we know that certain things on
principle,
not predictable,
which I put as you said,
I prefer because the idea that at the
initial condition of the universe and
then everything else would just acting
out the initial condition of the
universe.
That doesn't.
That doesn't mean it's not a romantic
notion.
Suddenly not right now when it comes to
consciousness,
I think we do have certain freedom.
We are much more constrained by physics
of course,
and by our paths and by our own
conscious desires and what our pounds
told us and what our environment tells
us.
We,
we all know that there's hundreds of
experiments that show how we can be
influenced.
But finally in the final analysis,
When you make a life that I'm talking
about really about critical decision
where you really think,
should I marry?
Should I go to this school,
have that,
could take this job,
that job.
Should I cheat on my taxes are not the
sort of,
these are things where you really
deliberate and I think on those
condition you are as free as you can be
when you,
when you bring your entire being and
time conscious being to that question
and title analysts analyze it on all the
the values,
condition.
Then you take,
you make a decision.
You are as free as you can ever be.
That is,
I think what free will is.
It's not a will.
That's totally free to do anything it
wants.
That's not possible.
Right?
So as jack mentioned,
you actually write a blog about books
you've read amazing books from.
I'm rushing from my son.
Might have been tough.
Yeah.
Neil gaiman,
carl sagan murakami.
So what is a book that early in your
life transform the way you saw the
world?
Something that changed your life,
I guess did the spokes are twisted
because he talks about some of these
problems,
you know,
he was one of the first discovery of the
unconscious because,
you know,
a little bit before freud when it wasn't
in the air and you know,
he makes all these claims that people
sort of,
I know the guys on the mass of charity
actually are very non charitable.
So he of really the first discovery of a
great line of the,
of the unconscious and that,
uh,
that really taught me.
And what do you think,
what do you think about the unconscious
w?
What do you think about freud with think
about these ideas?
What's,
what's just like dark matter in the
universe?
What's over there in that unconscious
a lot.
I mean much more than we think,
right?
This is what a lot of last hundred years
of research has shown.
So I think he was a genius,
misguided towards the end,
but he was all.
He started out as a neuroscientist.
He contributed,
he did studies on the,
um,
on the lamprey,
contributed himself to the neuron
hypothesis,
the idea that they're discrete units
that we call ourselves now.
And then he started,
then he,
he,
um,
bought,
you know,
about the unconscious and I think it's
too,
there's lots of stuff happening.
You feel this particular,
um,
when you're in a relationship and it
breaks our son now,
right?
And then you have this terrible.
You can have love and hate and lust and
anger and all.
It's mixed in.
And when you title analyzed yourself,
why am I so upset?
it's very,
very difficult to penetrate to those
basements,
those cabins in your mind because the
subconscious doesn't have access to
those,
but there they are made in the amygdala
or lots of other places.
They make you upset or angry or sad or
depressed.
And it's very difficult to try to
actually uncover the reason you can go
to a shrink.
You can talk wIth your friend endlessly.
You couldn't start finally a story why
this happened,
why you love or don't love her or
whatever,
but you don't really know whether that's
actually the way that that actually
happened because you simply don't have
access to those parts of the brain and
they're very powerful.
You think that's a feature or a bug of
our brain?
The fact that we have this deep
difficult to dive into subconscious.
I think it's a feature because
otherwise,
look,
we are like any other brain or nervous
system or computer.
We are severely band limited.
If we,
if everything I do,
every emotion I feel every eye movements
I make,
if all of that had to be under the
control of consciousness,
I couldn't.
I wouldn't be here.
Right?
So,
so what you do early on your brain,
you have to be conscious when you learn
things like typing or like riding on a
bike,
but then what you do,
you attain up our basal ganglia and
stratum you.
You train up different parts of your
brain and then once you do it
automatically like typing,
you can show you do it much faster
without even thinking about it because
you've got these highly specialized what
francis crick and I called zombie agents
that I can sort of taken care of that
while your consciousness can sort of
worry about the abstract sense of the
text to one of wide and I think that's
true for many,
many things,
but for the things like uh,
all the fights you had with the ex
girlfriend,
things that you would think are not
useful to still linger somewhere in the
subconscious.
So that seems like a bug that it would
staY there.
You think it would be better if you can
analyze and then get it out the system
or just forget it ever happened?
You know,
that that seems a very buggy kind of.
Yeah.
In general we don't have.
And that's probably functional.
We don't have an ability unless it's
extremely off cases,
clinical dissociation side when people
are heavily abused,
when they completely repressed the
memory.
But that doeSn't happen in,
in,
you know,
in normal people we don't have an
ability to move traumatic memories and
of course we suffer from that.
On the other hand,
probably if you had the ability to
constantly wipe your memory,
you'll probably do it to an extent that
isn't useful to you.
So
yeah,
it's a good question.
it's a balance.
So I'm on the books,
as jack mentioned,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but a broadly speaking in academia and
the different scientific disciplines,
certainly in engineering,
reading literature seems to be a rare
pursuit.
Perhaps I'm wrong in this,
but that's in my experience,
most people are much more technical
texts and do not sort of escape or seek
truth in literature.
Um,
it seems like you do a.
So what do you think is the value?
What do you think literature as the
pursuit of scientific truth,
do you think it's good?
It's useful for a
government access too much wide,
uh,
of a,
of human experiences.
How valuable do you think it is?
Well,
if you want to understand human nature
and nature in general,
then I think you'll have to better
understand wide variety of experiences,
not just sitting in a lab staring at a
screen and having a piece flashed onto
your planner,
melissa pushing a button.
That's what.
That's what I usually do that for most
psychologists do.
there's nothing wrong with that,
but you need to consider lots of other
strange states and literature is a
shortcut for this as well.
Yeah,
because literature,
that's what literature is all about.
All sorts of interesting experiences
that people have know the contingency of
it,
the fact that you know,
women experience a world different.
Black people experience the world
different and the one way to expense
that is reading all these different
literature and title.
Find out you,
you see everything so relative and you
read the book years ago they thought
about certain problems very,
very differently than the.
Then as today,
we today,
like any culture,
I think we know it all.
That's common to every culture.
Every culture believes that at a td.
They know it all and then you realize,
well,
there's other ways of viewing the
universe and some of them may have lots
of things in their favor.
So this is a question I wanted to ask
about timescale or scale in general,
when you with it or in general tried to
think about consciousness.
Trying to think about these ideas were
kind of naturally thinking human
timescales.
Do you um,
or,
and also,
uh,
entities that are sized close to humans,
do you think of things that are much
larger,
much smaller as containing consciousness
and do you think are things that take,
you know,
the ages?
Yeah,
to,
uh,
to operate in their conscious cause.
Effect cause effect.
It's a reallY good question.
So yeah,
I think a lot about small creatures
because experimentally,
you know,
a lot of people work on flies and bees.
I,
so most people just think they are
tolmatter.
They're just bags for heaven sake.
Right?
But if you look at their behavior,
like being,
he can recognize individual humans,
they have this very complicated way to
communicate.
If you've ever been involved with,
you know,
your pounds when they bought a house,
what sort of agonizing decision that is,
and bees have to do that once a year.
I'd when they swarm in the spring and
then they have this very elaborate way.
They have free not scouted the.
They go to the individual sites,
they come back,
they have this power,
this dance.
Literally where the dance was several
days.
They try to recruit other leaders.
Very complicated decision.
Wait,
when they finally wanting to make a
decision,
the entire swarm,
their scouts warm up the entire swim and
then go to one occasion.
They don't go to christian.
They go to one location that they scout
type agreed upon by themselves.
That's awesome.
But look at the circuit complexity.
It's 10 times more dense than anything
we have in our brain or they only have a
million neurons,
but then you amazingly complex,
complex behavior,
very complicated circuitry.
So there's no question that they
experienced.
Something they alive is very different.
They're tiny.
The only live you know for,
for workers live from maybe for two
months.
So I think it tells you this,
in principle,
the substrate of consciousness is the
substrate that maximizes the cause
effect power over all possible spatial
temporal grains.
So when I think about,
for example,
do you know the science fiction story,
the black cloud,
it's a classic,
I forgot holiday astronomer.
He has this cloud intervening between
the earth and the sun and I'm leading to
some sort of to global cooling.
This is written in the fifties.
It turns out you can using the,
the um,
the radio dish they communicate was
actually an entity to actually
intelligent entity and they,
they,
they sort of,
they convinced her to move away.
But here you have a radical different
entity.
And in pencil it says,
well,
you can measure the,
the integrated information in principle
at least.
And yes,
if that,
if the maximum of that occurs at a
timescale of month rather than an asset
for the fraction of a second.
Yes.
And they would experience life where
each moment is a month rather than,
um,
or microseconds,
right?
Rather than a fraction of a second in
the human case.
And so there may be forms of conscience
that we simply don't recognize for what
they are because they are so radical,
different from anything you and I are
used to.
Again,
that's why it's good to read.
Or to what science fiction where we want
to think about this like this.
Do you know stanislaw lem,
this polished and sectional he bought it
was turned into a hollywood movie.
His best novel.
So it was in the sixties,
very,
very engineered,
engineered back on his most interesting
novel is called the victoria's where I'm
human,
civilization they,
they,
they have this mission to this planet
and everything is just tired and they
discover machines.
Schumann's got killed and then these
machines took over.
There was a machine evolution at
dominion evolution.
He talks about this very vividly and
finally the dominant.
They're the dominant machine
intelligence organisms that survive are
gigantic clouds of little hexagonal
universal cell automata.
This was in the sixties,
but typically they're all lying on the
ground individual by themselves.
But in times of kaiser's econ,
communicate the assembling to gigantic
nets into clouds.
Billions of these particles and then
theY become hyper intelligent and they
can beat anything that humans can of
control it.
It,
it's a very beautiful and compelling
where you have an intelligence where
finally the schumann's leave the planet.
TheY simply unable to understand and
comprehend this creature and they can
say,
well,
either we can nuke the entire planet and
just tired or we just have to leave
because fundamentally it's an,
it's an alien.
It's so alien from us in our ideas that
we cannot communicate with them.
Yeah.
Actually in conversation.
So your talent to us steel steel from
brought up is that there could be to his
ideas that,
you know,
you already have these artificial
general intelligence like super smart or
maybe conscious beings in these sally or
tom and we just don't know how to talk
to them.
So that's the language of communication
because you don't know what to do with
it.
So that's one sort of view is a
consciousness is only something you can
measure.
So it's not conscious if you can't
measure it.
So you're making an ontological and an
epistemic statement.
One is they are,
they are.
it's just like seeing their multiverses.
That might be cool,
but I can't communicate with them.
I don't have.
I can't have any noncitizen.
That's an epistemic argument to.
Those are two different things,
so it may well be possible.
Look at another case that's happening
right now.
People are building these mini
organoids.
Do you know what is so you know you can
take stem cells from under your arm,
put it in a dish ad for transcription
factors,
and then you can induce him to to go
into large with large.
They have few millimeter.
They are like a half a million neurons
that looked like nerve cells in a dish
called mini organoids at harvard and
stanford.
EverYwhere they're building them.
It may be well be possible that they're
beginning to feel like something,
but we can't really communicate with
them right now.
So people are beginning to think about
the ethics of this,
right?
So yes,
he may be perfectly high,
but they made.
It's one question.
Are they conscious or not?
As totally separate question,
how would I know?
Those are two different things,
right?
If you could give advice to a young
researcher sort of dreaming of
understanding or creating human level
intelligence or consciousness,
what would you say follow your dreams?
Read quite widely.
Know I mean I,
I suppose,
what discipline,
what,
what is the pursuit that they should
take on?
Is it neuroscience?
Is a competition of cognitive science?
Is it philosophy?
Is it computer science or politics?
I
know in a sense that okay,
so the only known system that have high
level of intelligence is homo sapiens,
so if you wanted to build it,
it's probably good to continue to study
closely what humans do.
So cognitive neuroscience,
you know,
somewhere between cognitive neuroscience
on the one hand than some philosophy of
mind and then ai,
ai,
computer science.
You can look at all the original ideas,
new network.
They all came from neon signs,
right?
Or reinforcement,
whether it's snarky,
minsky billing is snarky or whether
it's,
you know,
the early in visal experiments that.
How about that?
Then gave rise to networks and then
multilayer networks,
so it may well be possible.
In fact,
some people are you there to make the
next big step in ai.
Once we realize the limits of deep
convolutional networks,
I didn't do certain things,
but they can't really understand.
I did,
don't they?
They don't really.
They can't really.
I can't really show in one image,
I can show you a single image of
somebody pick pocket who steals a wallet
from a purse.
You immediately know that's a
pickpocket.
right now.
Computer system will just say,
well,
it's a man.
It's a woman.
It's a purse.
Unless you turn this machine on,
showing it 100,000
pickpockets.
I taught it doesn't.
It doesn't have this easy understanding
that you have.
All right,
so so some people make the ironman in
order to go to the next step or you
really want to build machines that
understand in a way,
you and I,
we have to go to psychology.
We need to understand how we do it in
our brains,
enable us to do it,
and so therefore being on the cast,
it's also so exciting to try to
understand better our nature and then to
build to take some of those insight and
build them.
So I think the most exciting thing is
somewhere in the interface between
cognitive science,
neuroscience,
ai,
computer science and philosophy of mind.
beautiful.
yeah.
I'd say if there is from the machine
learning for from the computer science,
computer vision perspective may have the
research is kind of ignore the way the
human brain works.
You can or even psychology or literature
or studying the brain.
I would hope josh tannenbaum talks about
bringing that in more and more and
that's a.
So you've worked on some amazing stuff
throughout your life.
What's the thing that you're really
excited about?
What's the mystery that you would love
to uncover in the near term beyond
beyond all the mr dharia already
surrounded by.
Well,
so that's this tuck shop called the
cloth [inaudible].
Underneath our cortex is a big.
You have one on the left,
right underneath this,
underneath the insula.
It's very thin,
it's like one millimeter,
it's embedded in,
in wiring in white matter is,
it's very difficult to image and um,
it has,
uh,
it has connection to every cortical
region and francis kicked the last paper
you have,
have he dictated corrections the day he
died in hospital on this paper.
He and we,
it hypothesized,
well because it has this unique anatomy,
it gets input from every cortical area
and projects back to every area that the
function of this structure is similar.
That it's just a metaphor to the role of
conducting a sYmphony orchestra.
You have all the different cortical
players,
you have some that do motion,
some they do with theory of mind that
in,
for social interaction and calais and
hearing and all the different modules
and cortex,
but of course what consciousness is.
Consciousness puts it all together into
one package,
right?
The binding problem,
all of that.
And this is really the function because
it has relatively few nuanced compared
to cop cappex,
but it,
it,
it talks it a,
it seeks input from all of them and they
project back to all of them.
And so we're testing that right now,
we've got this beautiful new owner
reconstruction in the mouse called count
of thought and kind of found new onset
or in the classroom that have the most
widespread connection of any nerve new
on I've ever seen.
They're very,
they,
you have individually onto sit in the
clouds from tiny.
But then they had this single neurons
have this huge external tree that cover
both ipsy and contract of apple cortex
and kind of using,
you know,
fancy tools like optogenetics,
titled term.
Those nuanced on honor often studied
what happens in the,
in the malls.
So this thing is perhaps where the parts
become the whole interface.
It's one of this conscious,
it's a verY good way of putting it where
the individual parts turned into the
whole of the whole,
of the conscious experience.
Well,
with that,
thank you very much for being here
today.
Thank you so much.